just don't let Abby see you eating cake
hey Jill
we know you're a cool mom and everything
but we still can't get over your wicked
dance moves most parents try to keep
themselves off of tick-tock but you
rolled right in with a huge smile on
your face
Kendall is lucky to have you as a mother
even though you stir the pot more than a
few times on Dance Moms
could you tell their parents in front of
their kids that their kids were hot
nothing it's no secret that the girls
from Dance Moms have a huge social media
following millions of fans want to see
what they're up to and they love
watching them sing and dance on tik-tok
we've got the 11 best Dance Moms
tik-tok videos lined up for you so don't
go anywhere Kendall and Jill shake
things up Kendall and Jill vertes have
always been super close I want what's
best for you which is why we're not
surprised to see them dancing together
on tik-tok Kendall posted a video of her
mom and herself dancing to the song
shake it by metro station and her fans
went wild Jill had a huge smile on her
face and seemed super happy to be
dancing with her daughter on the small
screen this tik-tok video has over 2
million likes so Jill's probably feeling
super loved right now Kendall and Nia
take a trip down memory lane
Kendall birthdays is back at it again
but this time she invited her dear old
Dance Moms Costa Nia Sioux to tag along
in the hilarious tik tok video we see
Kendall and Nia re-enacting some of
their most dramatic moments on Dance
Moms but the girls don't stop there they
kick things up a notch by imitating
their mothers facial expressions - it's
nice to see Kendall and Nia making light
of dark situations why are you so
obsessed with me when it comes to
posting viral videos on tick-tock Nia su
has got it in the bag but she took
things to the next level when she
invited Maddie Ziegler Gino and a friend
to dance along with her Nia Maddie and
the boys danced to Mariah Carey's hit
song why are you so obsessed with me and
fans completely lost it we hope to see
Maddie and Nia hanging out especially
when they're putting their talents to
good use Sara Dorer Gianna and Jimena
go all out when it comes to posting
tik-tok videos Dance Moms newest wave of
dancers knows how it's done Sara Dorer
Dianna has uploaded plenty of hilarious
videos to her tik-tok account
some of her favorite ones showcase her
adorable dog Reese but the best one by
far is the one of Sarah and Janina
dancing and singing along to Rowan
Blanchard and Sabrina carpenters take on
the world
Maddie and Kenzie bring it on is there
any sister duo more iconic than Maddie
and Mackenzie Ziegler yeah we didn't
think so
the dance moms stars got together to
create a super entertaining tick tock
video that had fans going wild in no
time in this video the Ziggler sisters
danced along to a remix version of jump
up superstar and their dance moves are
on fire Kenzie posted this video on her
tik-tok account and it quickly garnered
over 480 thousand likes
Kenzie's morning ritual Mackenzie
Ziggler might be only 15 years old but
she's got a stamina of someone twice her
age how did you pick that up so fast oh
I guess I was just being present she's a
famous tick tock er who never leaves her
fans waiting which is why she sometimes
multitasks to upload daily content in
this tick tock video Kenzie is brushing
her teeth and dancing at the same time
Kenzie makes sure to hit every beat
while dancing to Y&W Meli's 2:23 and
according to Kenzie she had just learned
the choreography 10 seconds before
performing it
Jojo she was energetic dance moves Jojo
with the bow bow isn't your average
teenager first of all she's got more
energy than a Walt Disney amusement park
and she's not afraid to show it
Jojo posted a tick tock video of herself
dancing to a mash-up up wanna be by
Spice Girls and let's get it started by
the Black Eyed Peas
JoJo's dance moves were on fire and she
even beckoned her fans to count how many
times her knees went in and out Brinn
Rumble oh and her besties we all know
that burn rum follow is a sweet heart no
matter what the cast of Dance Moms may
say have you guys
Brin recently posted a video of her and
three friends dancing along to Missy
Elliott's lose control the girls
performed their tick-tock video in a car
and it looks like they were having a
blast Brin doesn't have the biggest
following on tick-tock but she does have
2.9 million followers on Instagram
Maddie and Kenzie are at it again Maddie
and Mackenzie Ziegler are two peas in a
pod and when they happen to be sleeping
under the same roof they make the best
out of it Kenzie posted a video of
Maddie and herself dancing along to
Blanco Brown's the getup
and according to Kinsey Maddie had
wanted to dance to the song for a super
long time
the sisters looked flawless and knocked
their performances out of the park
Hannah and Lilly rocked the catwalk
Hannah Collins and Liliana catchman are
part of the new age group of Dance Moms
stars I really like the friendships that
I've created from this that hasn't
stopped them from putting on a tick tock
show Hannah posted a video of Lilly and
herself dancing and walking toward the
camera she used some special effects
that turned her video from average to
spectacular Maddie and Cameron have a
shake off it looks like the song shaken
by metro station is a popular one among
stick talkers Maddie's BFF
Cameron fields posted a video of Maddie
and himself having an epic shake off and
fans lost it over their choreography and
that's a wrap before you go tell us
which tick tock video is your favorite
in the comments below subscribe to the
things and give this video a big thumbs
up thanks for watching we'll see you
again soon
[Music]